Particularly when you're dealing with a language like C++, where it doesn't have guide rails or guard rails. In other words, there's no implicit guidance in the language design. You can do anything you want, but let's go back to the axe conversation. Yeah, cutting your hand off is also an option, you know, and we talk about foot guns and things like that. You know, blowing your foot off, why stop at the foot? You know, just take out the whole limb. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 190, recorded on July 11th, 2024. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we interview Kevlin Henney,
特别是在处理像 C++ 这样的语言时，它没有导轨或护栏。换句话说，语言设计中没有隐含的指导。你可以做任何你想做的事，但让我们回到斧头的话题。是的，切掉你的手也是一种选择，你知道，我们谈论的是“脚枪”（foot guns）之类的事情。你知道，把你的脚炸掉，为什么只停留在脚上呢？你知道，干脆把整个肢体都切掉。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 190 期，录制于 2024 年 7 月 11 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起采访 Kevlin Henney，
and we chat about C++, Python, zombie apocalypses, and more. Note that this is part one of what will probably be a four or five part series. Well, the listener really just missed out on some, I mean, I had props even. Yeah. We will, I mean, we'll start with our introduction now. But we just spent, what's the time stamp? 20 minutes? So, I mean, technically we might be able to piece together half of an episode from just Bryce's side of the conversation. But then you'll miss out on everything that Kevlin said. We were talking about, what are the topics we covered we covered ai apocalypse zombie apocalypse wait wait we
我们聊了 C++、Python、僵尸启示录等等。请注意，这是可能分为四到五部分系列的第一部分。好吧，听众真的错过了一些东西，我的意思是，我甚至准备了道具。是的。我的意思是，我们现在从介绍开始。但我们刚刚花了，时间戳是多少？20 分钟？所以，我的意思是，从技术上讲，我们也许能从 Bryce 的对话中拼凑出半集节目。但那样你就会错过 Kevlin 所说的一切。我们当时在谈论，我们涵盖了哪些主题？我们涵盖了人工智能启示录、僵尸启示录，等等，等等，我们
covered how training neural nets is hard yeah data acquisition especially in the form of videos uh your son's admiration and aspiration for axes and more i'm not sure the the the henny plan the henny family zombie apocalypse plan yeah we we have it all um you know and and that all kind of connected together um with uh we then ended up with talking about forests and different population density. And English whack thereof. I insulted the cities of Cambridge and Oxford. That's right. And Cambridge just accidentally.
涵盖了训练神经网络是多么困难，是的，数据获取，特别是视频形式的数据，呃，你儿子对斧头的钦佩和渴望等等。我不确定 Henney 一家的僵尸启示录计划，是的，我们，我们都有，嗯，你知道，这一切都以某种方式联系在一起，嗯，我们最后谈到了森林和不同的人口密度。以及英语的匮乏。我侮辱了剑桥和牛津这两个城市。没错。而且剑桥还是无意的。
Yeah, Cambridge accidentally. And then we went back and made sure that, you know, and actually tied that together with zombies. But also, yeah, there was a little bit in there about you've got iodine tablets for radiation. Yes, I do. Actually, Bryce initially said, opened with, I'm not really a prepper, and then revealed actually that perhaps he was and just had not yet acknowledged it and it was masking. I'm the Manhattan version of a prepper because Manhattanites have no space. And so if you're a Manhattanite prepper, you can't have a bunker. You can't like stock up on like lots of stuff. You have to be space
是的，剑桥是无意的。然后我们回去确保，你知道，实际上把这一点和僵尸联系起来。但还有，是的，里面有一点关于你有用于辐射的碘片的内容。是的，我有。实际上，Bryce 最初说，开场白是，我真的不是一个末日生存狂，然后透露实际上他可能就是，只是还没有承认，而且是在掩饰。我是曼哈顿版的末日生存狂，因为曼哈顿人没有空间。所以如果你是一个曼哈顿生存狂，你不能有一个地堡。你不能像囤积很多东西那样。你必须在空间上
efficient about it. And I have the space efficient prepper things. Yeah. So, you know, there's all of these things that we talked about. The relative efficiency that the LLM model, you know, you need a lot of training data. That's the thing that we see. LLMs are the modern, this paradigm of AI is thirsty for data and for power. But maybe humans, that's one thing. That's a trick that we might want to think about in terms of optimization is that humans do an awful lot with far less training data and a lot less energy consumption. So that's potentially an interesting direction. And that all related back to your girlfriend learning Swift, bizarrely enough.
精打细算。我有那种节省空间的生存装备。是的。所以，你知道，我们谈论了所有这些事情。LLM 模型所需的相对效率，你知道，你需要大量的训练数据。这就是我们所看到的。LLM 是现代的，这种人工智能范式渴望数据和电力。但也许人类，这是一件值得思考的事情，在优化方面，人类用少得多的训练数据和少得多的能源消耗做了很多事情。所以这可能是一个有趣的方向。而这一切都与你女朋友学习 Swift 有关，奇怪的是。
Yes. Learning Swift and wanting to create a tennis app that recognizes the type of tennis shot that you're making. And this is the point where a conner can insert earlier audio. So, and of course, when we were talking, when the zombie apocalypse thing was also related to the fact that we ended up talking about, we started off with robot apocalypse or the AI apocalypse. And then I said, actually, we might be strangely prepared in Bristol, because Bristol City Council, over 10 years ago, actually issued a plan for
是的。学习 Swift 并想创建一个能识别你正在进行的网球击球类型的网球应用程序。这就是 Connor 可以插入之前音频的地方。所以，当然，当我们谈话时，僵尸启示录的事情也与我们最终谈论的事实有关，我们从机器人启示录或人工智能启示录开始。然后我说，实际上，我们在布里斯托尔可能出奇地有准备，因为布里斯托尔市议会，在 10 多年前，实际上发布了一项计划，针对
the event of a zombie or undead invasion. And you can actually find it if you Google Bristol City Council zombie plan. I do wonder, like, why did they do this? I think it was somebody was bored you know sitting in the council office they kind of put together two or three pages just brief um and uh you know but that that and we do actually that for a number of years and i don't think it's restarted since the pandemic but there was a there's a zombie walk kind of once a year um uh and you know honestly the difference between the zombie walk and a standard Saturday night
僵尸或不死族入侵事件。如果你在谷歌上搜索“布里斯托尔市议会僵尸计划”，你实际上可以找到它。我确实想知道，他们为什么要这样做？我想是有人无聊了，你知道，坐在议会办公室里，他们整理了两三页，只是简短的，嗯，而且，你知道，但那，我们确实做了好几年，我不认为大流行之后又重新开始了，但每年都有一次僵尸游行，嗯，而且，你知道，老实说，僵尸游行和布里斯托尔市中心一个普通的周六晚上之间的区别，
in the center of Bristol, difficult to distinguish, I have to confess. But, you know, there's a kind of thing there. So there's a kind of an association there. And, you know, Bristol marches to the beat of a very different drum sometimes. But having a zombie plan was kind of cool, I have to admit.
很难区分，我必须承认。但是，你知道，那里有一种东西。所以那里有一种关联。而且，你知道，布里斯托尔有时会按照非常不同的节奏行进。但我必须承认，有一个僵尸计划还是很酷的。
Even if done just in jest. I do have to ask, we had this really nice dinner when we were in bristol and it was on like a tuesday or wednesday and it's a very nice restaurant there was nobody else there and this and there were a bunch of restaurants where like they were just like closed during the weekdays do people not like eat out in bristol the weekdays? Is that just not a thing? It is, but it depends where you were because the, so that would have been the OCCU conference, the ACCU conference.
即使只是开玩笑。我确实得问一下，我们在布里斯托尔时吃了一顿非常好的晚餐，那是在周二或周三，那是一家非常好的餐厅，没有其他人，而且有一堆餐厅在工作日就关门了，人们在布里斯托尔的工作日不出去吃饭吗？那不是常态吗？是常态，但这取决于你在哪里，因为，那应该是 OCCU 会议，ACCU 会议。
Yes. And I'm going to guess you were within five to 10 minutes walk of the hotel. 15 minutes or so, yeah. 15 minutes, yeah. So it depends on the direction that you went, but the chances are in the center of Bristol, you've got, and that's April, early, middle of the in the center of bristol you've got um and that's that's april early middle of the week center of bristol you're not likely to find as many people in fact it's a great time to go for a dinner um you're more likely to find people eating out later in the week or elsewhere in bristol so the center bristol is more likely to empty out and particularly
是的。我猜你离酒店步行五到十分钟。15 分钟左右，是的。15 分钟，是的。所以这取决于你走的方向，但在布里斯托尔市中心，你有，那是四月，早，月中，在布里斯托尔市中心，你有，嗯，那是四月，早，月中，在布里斯托尔市中心，你不太可能找到很多人，事实上，这是一个吃晚餐的好时间，你更有可能在周晚些时候或布里斯托尔的其他地方找到出去吃饭的人，所以布里斯托尔市中心更有可能空出来，特别是
certain parts particularly those near um uh the conference hotel uh tend to be much more business district and so you don't tend to have people hanging around as much um whereas thursday onwards in the center it tends to get a lot busier um but generally later early in the week if people are going out uh it tends to be much more local so you're going to be in different parts of bristol so yeah in other words, if you're visiting Bristol and you want to make sure that you can get somewhere nice for dinner, then go into the center because people aren't going to be there if it's early in the week. That clearly doesn't work for December. There are Christmas parties all over the place, but that's actually quite a good strategy.
某些部分，特别是那些靠近会议酒店的部分，往往更属于商业区，所以你往往不会有那么多人闲逛，而周四以后在市中心往往会变得忙碌得多，但总的来说，如果人们在周初出去，往往更本地化，所以你会去布里斯托尔的不同地方，所以是的，换句话说，如果你去布里斯托尔旅游，想确保能找到一个吃晚餐的好地方，那就去市中心，因为如果是在周初，人们不会在那里。这显然不适用于十二月。到处都是圣诞派对，但这实际上是一个相当不错的策略。
Go to the places that people don't go in the evening. So we should. What is the big business? Pause, pause, pause. Before, we still haven't introduced Kevlin. I mean, 98% of our listeners know who you are, Kevlin, because I think you've come up, I don't know, a handful of times. I like to mention your talks now and then. But a brief introduction. Writer, speaker, independent consultant. You are probably most well known for
去人们晚上不去的地方。所以我们应该。大生意是什么？暂停，暂停，暂停。在此之前，我们还没有介绍 Kevlin。我的意思是，98% 的听众都知道你是谁，Kevlin，因为我觉得你已经出现过，我不知道，几次了。我偶尔会提到你的演讲。但做一个简短的介绍。作家、演讲者、独立顾问。你可能最出名的是
both some of your books, all of your books and your talks. I mean, I, for a while, used to gift 97 Things Every Programmer Should Know whenever I would leave a company, which I've only done twice, I guess. But I would, for the people that, you know, I wanted to say goodbye to, that was the go-to book that I would give people. I would love to say that, like, these are my top five favorite things from it. I have to admit, I've never, I've never,
你的一些书，你所有的书和你的演讲。我的意思是，我有一段时间，每当我离开一家公司时，我都会赠送《每个程序员都应该知道的 97 件事》，我猜我只做过两次。但我会，对于那些，你知道，我想告别的人，那是我会送给人们的首选书籍。我很想说，这些是我从中挑选出的最喜欢的五件事。我必须承认，我从来没有，我从来没有，
I've never even heard this book. You're famously not a book or podcast person, though, so you don't listen to podcasts, you don't read books. See, I know Kevlin for his excellent talks and, of course, his famous witty humor but yes 97 i was gonna say i'd love to rattle off the top four or five uh but it was like i want to say a few years ago oh please well no i was gonna say i can't because it was like 20 i want to say it was like 2016 that i read the book. I'm not sure if that lines up with
我甚至从来没听说过这本书。不过，你以不是书虫或播客爱好者而闻名，所以你不听播客，也不读书。看，我知道 Kevlin 是因为他精彩的演讲，当然还有他著名的机智幽默，但是是的，97，我本来想说我很想列举前四五条，但那就像我想说几年前，哦，请，好吧，不，我本来想说我不能，因为那就像 20，我想说那就像 2016 年我读了这本书。我不确定这是否与
roughly when it came out. I had like a few of them that I really, really liked, but now it's been like close to a decade that like I've internalized that stuff. And it's just like a part of the way that I program. And I know that a lot of them overlapped with my favorite talk of yours, which I told you when we met in craft conf back in May, which was declarative thinking, declarative practice. There's a ton of stuff in that talk that like really influenced the way that I was writing C++ at the time, because C++ famously is not, I mean, you can code any way you want in C++, but a lot of this stuff that you get out of the box doesn't, you know, it's not immutable by default, like Rust or some other language, right?
它出版的时间大致吻合。我有几条我非常非常喜欢的，但现在已经快十年了，我已经内化了那些东西。它就像我编程方式的一部分。我知道其中很多与我最喜欢你的演讲重叠，我在五月份在 Craft Conf 见到你时告诉过你，那就是声明式思维，声明式实践。那个演讲中有很多东西真的影响了我当时编写 C++ 的方式，因为 C++ 众所周知不是，我的意思是，你可以在 C++ 中以任何方式编码，但你开箱即用得到的很多东西，你知道，它默认不是不可变的，不像 Rust 或其他语言，对吧？
Anyway, so we will link some of the books. There's also i i think the java version of the 97 things book yeah that that we're talking about the pandemic um earlier on and um in fact during the during pre-conversation um bryce in his non-prepper mode was basically saying he had a whole load of n95 marks masks before the pandemic and that was actually air quality in california influencing that um uh and uh so therefore that gets to talking about the pandemic the the java version of the 97 things um but was finished in the first wave of lockdowns um uh because what else are you going to do um so it's me and Tricia G. Tricia used to work for JetBrains. And kind of after that, I got a call.
总之，我们会链接一些书。还有，我想 Java 版的 97 件事那本书，是的，我们谈论大流行，早些时候，而且，事实上，在预对话期间，Bryce 在他非生存狂模式下基本上说他在大流行之前有一大堆 N95 口罩，那实际上是加州的空气质量影响了这一点，而且，所以这就谈到了大流行，Java 版的 97 件事，但在第一波封锁中完成了，因为你还能做什么呢，所以是我和 Tricia G。Tricia 曾经为 JetBrains 工作。在那之后，我接到了一个电话。
I got a message from Peter Somerlad, who may be known to some of the listeners. Peter's been involved in C++ forever. And particularly some committee work, unit testing, stuff that he's done, refactoring work that he's done. But Peter was interested in, oh, maybe there'd be interest in doing a C++ version.
我收到了 Peter Somerlad 的一条消息，一些听众可能知道他。Peter 一直参与 C++。特别是委员会工作、单元测试、他所做的重构工作。但 Peter 感兴趣的是，哦，也许人们会对制作 C++ 版本感兴趣。
And unfortunately, O'Reilly weren't quite on board with that at that particular point, which is a shame. But the 97 Things thing, that book actually came out in 2010. So yeah, it predates 2016 by quite a way. And it is the thing I quite like about that, although I like the Java one, and the same if I did a C++ one or a Python one or whatever. The funny thing about choosing a specific technology is by definition, the technology is going to date.
不幸的是，O'Reilly 在那个特定时刻并没有完全同意，这很遗憾。但 97 件事那本书实际上是在 2010 年出版的。所以是的，它比 2016 年早了很多。我非常喜欢这一点，虽然我喜欢 Java 版，如果我做 C++ 版或 Python 版或其他什么，也是一样。选择特定技术的有趣之处在于，根据定义，技术会过时。
And I'm not saying that the general programmer one is timeless. But because it was trying to, because I told people, okay, what do you want to tell other people? This is the idea. People volunteered things, you know, it was a very kind of open submission type of approach. By definition, they're not anchoring on, well, here you are, you're using, you're currently using C++98, this is what you're going to do. Or you are currently using Java 6, and this is what you're going to do. So I'm just rescaling the timeline, trying to get my versions right. Or you're considering using Python 3, 2010, probably weren't. You're using Python 2.3 or 2.4. The point there is that that wasn't the goal of the book. It was like, I don't know who I'm speaking to, but they code. What can I tell them? So what the interesting thing is that only four years after the Java one's come out, it's probably dated more in some ways than the 97 things every programmer should have.
我并不是说通用的程序员那本是永恒的。但因为它试图，因为我告诉人们，好吧，你想告诉别人什么？这就是想法。人们自愿提交东西，你知道，这是一种非常开放的提交方式。根据定义，他们不会锚定在，好吧，你现在正在使用 C++98，这就是你要做的。或者你现在正在使用 Java 6，这就是你要做的。所以我只是在重新调整时间线，试图把我的版本搞对。或者你正在考虑使用 Python 3，2010 年，可能没有。你正在使用 Python 2.3 或 2.4。重点是那不是书的目标。就像，我不知道我在对谁说话，但他们会编码。我能告诉他们什么？所以有趣的是，在 Java 版出版仅四年后，它在某些方面可能比《每个程序员都应该知道的 97 件事》过时得更多。
Because the Java one is specifically talking about this version, this framework, this whatever. And a C++ one would have a similar issue because you'd probably have somebody submitting saying, hey, you're going to program modern C++. Let's pretend that we started developing that book this year. That means that you'd have some people saying, oh, well, maybe we should be pushing C++ 23. But other people say, oh, you've still got to get on board with 17 and 20. But if I'm reading this in five years time, 17 and 20 is looking much further in the rearview mirror and i'm thinking well that's over a decade ago and suddenly it's become dated and the notion of modern has shifted and there's that constantly moving window so the curious thing is that the
因为 Java 版专门谈论这个版本，这个框架，这个什么的。而 C++ 版也会有类似的问题，因为你可能会有人提交说，嘿，你要编写现代 C++。让我们假设我们今年开始开发那本书。这意味着你会有人说，哦，好吧，也许我们应该推动 C++ 23。但其他人说，哦，你仍然必须接受 17 和 20。但如果我在五年后读到这个，17 和 20 在后视镜里看起来更远了，我在想，好吧，那是十多年前的事了，突然它变得过时了，现代的概念已经转移了，有一个不断移动的窗口，所以奇怪的是
2010 book if you read in 2016 doesn't seem that doesn't seem that old But even less than six years after the Java one came out, you can already see a gap opening up because it's trying to speak to a specific technology. So there's kind of an interesting thing there. And I think it appeals to, and you were saying that you kind of internalize things. And I think that that's the thing, is that it is intentionally about the underlying principles rather than some of the technical specifics that i could go and easily look up in the read me or online somewhere so there's they the books i guess have slightly different goals but they also have different aging properties yeah no it's it's super interesting uh and i i haven't read the java one but i would definitely think that the 97 uh like the original one it has
2010 年的书如果你在 2016 年读，看起来并不那么旧。但即使在 Java 版出版不到六年，你已经可以看到差距在扩大，因为它试图对一种特定的技术说话。所以那里有一种有趣的事情。而且我认为它吸引了，你说你内化了东西。我认为这就是重点，它是有意关于潜在原则，而不是我可以轻易在自述文件或网上查到的某些技术细节，所以这些书，我想，有略微不同的目标，但它们也有不同的老化属性。是的，不，这超级有趣，我没有读过 Java 版，但我绝对认为 97，就像原版一样，它有
just like a lot of the advice given is timeless advice it's not like you said attached to any version or uh is gonna you know 10 years from now be no longer like some of it's uh very generic but like i remember too at the time like you sort of go through at some point in your career like you are learning the style that you like to code in. And at the time I was reading it, like I hadn't fully, uh, you know, concretize the way that I like to write code, but then like you start to read books like that and that talk as well, declarative thinking and declarative practice. And there's another one by Ben Dean, uh, that covers a lot of the same stuff, uh, called,
就像给出的很多建议是永恒的建议，它不像你说的附属于任何版本，或者 10 年后将不再像，其中一些非常通用，但就像我也记得当时，就像你在职业生涯的某个时刻经历的那样，你正在学习你喜欢的编码风格。在我读它的时候，我还没有完全，你知道，具体化我喜欢写代码的方式，但然后你开始读像那样的书，还有那个演讲，声明式思维和声明式实践。还有 Ben Dean 的另一篇，涵盖了很多同样的东西，叫做，
uh, what is his called it's easy to use hard to misuse uh like applying declarative thinking or something like that and like both of those talks it just showed a way to write c++ that is not like the default and it makes it more robust and uh and anyways like a few years after that though i had kind of like settled on like you know you've seen enough code you've reviewed enough prs and like i very quickly can be like look at a pr and code someone's written and be like this is i really really like this this is high quality code and then this other stuff it's like even if it's it's written but just formatted a certain way it's like instantly gives you like chills or something i'm sure both of you have
呃，他的叫什么，易于使用，难以误用，就像应用声明式思维之类的，这两个演讲都展示了一种编写 C++ 的方式，它不像默认的那样，它使它更健壮，而且，无论如何，几年后，我已经有点定型了，你知道，你见过足够的代码，你审查过足够的 PR，我很快就能看一个 PR 和别人写的代码，然后说，这，我真的非常喜欢这个，这是高质量的代码，然后其他东西，就像即使它是写出来的，但只是以某种方式格式化，就像瞬间让你感到寒意，我相信你们两个都有
had that experience when yeah yeah everything is possible but you don't necessarily have a quality filter in that sense you don't or you don't know why something is good and and i think particularly when you're dealing with a language like c++ where it doesn't have guide rails or guard rails in other words there's no implicit guidance in the language design right you can do anything you want but let's go back to the axe conversation yeah cutting your hand off is also an option um you know and we talk about foot guns and things like that you know blowing your foot off why why stop at the foot you know just just just just take out the whole limb the point there is this but you see see there's that one person who has that very important use case where cutting their foot off gets them an extra 5% performance.
过那种经历，当，是的，是的，一切皆有可能，但你并不一定有那种意义上的质量过滤器，或者你不知道为什么某事是好的，而且我认为特别是在处理像 C++ 这样的语言时，它没有导轨或护栏，换句话说，语言设计中没有隐含的指导，对吧，你可以做任何你想做的事，但让我们回到斧头的话题，是的，切掉你的手也是一种选择，嗯，你知道，我们谈论的是“脚枪”之类的事情，你知道，把你的脚炸掉，为什么，为什么停在脚上，你知道，干脆，干脆，干脆把整个肢体都切掉，重点是这个，但你看，你看，有那个人，他有那个非常重要的用例，切掉脚能给他带来 5% 的额外性能。
And so, you know, we have to have the axe. And we have to have that. So therefore, yeah. And so there is that issue that because there isn't – and it's interesting dealing with different kind of language, programming language cultures. And I think that's actually one of the really interesting things is that when you you look at how people use language is often a cultural thing yeah it's not a national culture but it is there are um so one of the things uh early in my career i worked uh i think most yeah initially my c++ was under windows uh was under windows then i went and um and then i was working on unix and um x windows and it was really and therefore you know um posix standards and all kinds of stuff and it was really
所以，你知道，我们必须有斧头。我们必须有那个。所以，是的。所以存在那个问题，因为没有——而且处理不同种类的语言，编程语言文化很有趣。而且我认为这实际上是非常有趣的事情之一，当你观察人们如何使用语言时，通常是一种文化事物，是的，它不是一种民族文化，但它是，有，嗯，所以其中一件事，在我职业生涯早期，我工作，我想大多数，是的，最初我的 C++ 是在 Windows 下，是在 Windows 下，然后我去，嗯，然后我在 Unix 和 X Windows 上工作，这真的，因此，你知道，嗯，POSIX 标准和各种各样的东西，这真的
interesting just looking it's like okay here's the same language but already the influences and the way that people think about their just just everything from naming to error reporting conventions and things like that was already shaped by the context they were in. So it was one language, but two very different cultures already well-defined. And these days we have an even larger spread. And there is quite the normalizing characteristic.
很有趣，只是看着，就像，好吧，这是同一种语言，但人们思考命名到错误报告约定之类的一切方式，已经受到了他们所处环境的影响。所以它是一种语言，但已经是两种定义明确的截然不同的文化。而这些天我们有更大的传播。而且确实有一种标准化的特征。
Anything is possible, but that also is a real challenge for anybody working. And particularly anybody working with code that has been developed over many eras. Because you've got all these different eras of language and what is received good practice, and then you've got the individual preferences or the backgrounds of the developers who came in. Whereas when you look at the Java space, I'm not going to say all it's uniform but there's a much stronger uh core culture and again you kind of get the thing i think python's interestingly um caught between a couple of extremes there's a very strong core sense of pythonic but python is also everybody's favorite second language and there and a lot of people that are python tourists so sometimes you stumble
一切皆有可能，但这对于任何工作的人来说也是一个真正的挑战。特别是任何处理跨越多个时代开发的代码的人。因为你有所有这些不同时代的语言和什么是公认的好做法，然后你有开发人员的个人偏好或背景。而当你观察 Java 空间时，我不会说所有东西都是统一的，但有一个更强大的核心文化，同样，你有点得到那个东西，我认为 Python 有趣地，嗯，夹在两个极端之间，有一种非常强大的核心 Python 风格感，但 Python 也是每个人最喜欢的第二语言，而且那里，很多人是 Python 游客，所以有时你会偶然发现
across code that you go like yeah this is this is elegant, this is Pythonic, this is kind of like the received wisdom. And then you step outside that and you're looking and it's just like, okay, this person is definitely a tourist. They've obviously got the code. They're thinking from, in a scripting sense, they're using a common subset of the language and they're kind of just making something work.
代码，你会觉得，是的，这是优雅的，这是 Python 风格的，这有点像公认的智慧。然后你走出那个范围，你看着它，就像，好吧，这个人绝对是一个游客。他们显然有代码。他们正在从，在脚本意义上思考，他们正在使用语言的一个通用子集，他们只是在让某事工作。
But it's not their primary language and that shows. And they're kind of making do. And they've got a very kind of imperative style, even though Python actually allows you to be a lot more expressive than that. Going back to Connor's observations about the kind of declarative style of thinking, you can be highly economic in Python, but you can also be staggeringly verbose. And that's the, you know, and that's, it's from where people are coming from. And that I think is really interesting and is a challenge. I think for anybody coming into any language is what is the received culture there? And how well is it supported as being considered normal? But then also how much, how does time affect this? Younger languages have less variation over time. But if I picked up a book, you know, I'm just looking over at my C++ bookshelf,
但这不是他们的主要语言，这显而易见。他们有点在凑合。他们有一种非常命令式的风格，即使 Python 实际上允许你比那更具表现力。回到 Connor 关于声明式思维方式的观察，你可以在 Python 中非常经济，但你也可以令人震惊地冗长。这就是，你知道，这就是，它来自人们来自哪里。而且我认为这真的很有趣，是一个挑战。我认为对于任何进入任何语言的人来说，什么是那里的公认文化？它作为被认为是正常的被支持得有多好？但然后还有，时间如何影响这一点？年轻的语言随着时间的推移变化较小。但如果我拿起一本书，你知道，我只是看着我的 C++ 书架，
and it's kind of like, if I pick up one of those books, I've got... So if I pick up a book from the early 90s, then its idea of good is going to be really different from the stuff that's coming out in the early 2000s. It's going to be different to what is coming out now. And it's like any legacy code base, that's a real challenge for anybody, isn't it? They're coming into it. It's going like, okay, the file started in the late 90s, and here I am in the 2020s, and I've got everything in between. And I think that's a challenge for people working with C++ when they're learning it because it's such a large language. It's a case of like, well, what do
它有点像，如果我拿起其中一本书，我有……所以如果我拿起一本 90 年代初的书，那么它对好的想法将与 2000 年代初出来的东西非常不同。它将与现在出来的东西不同。就像任何遗留代码库一样，这对任何人来说都是一个真正的挑战，不是吗？他们进入它。就像，好吧，文件开始于 90 年代末，而我在这里处于 2020 年代，我拥有介于两者之间的一切。而且我认为这对学习 C++ 的人来说是一个挑战，因为它是一种如此庞大的语言。这就像，好吧，你教什么？你几乎必须问那个人，你从哪里来？因为如果你是为自己写代码，或者你正在为一个新项目写代码，实际上，我的回答可能与别人说，是的，我们正在处理，你知道，我们自 2000 年以来一直在维护的驱动程序，非常非常不同，那么你是低级的，你是历史性的，你可能没有超过 C，你知道，它就像，它有点像，它有点像带有少量 C++ 特性的整洁 C，但它可能非常命令式，而且它非常低级，它与 C 编码风格的共同点比它与别人会说，嘿，猜猜你可以用 C++ 23 做这个的共同点更多，所以你，它有点像，我是在学习旧的，我是在学习盎格鲁-撒克逊
you teach? You almost have to ask the person, where are you coming from? Because if you are writing code for yourself or you're writing code for a new project, actually, my response may be very, very different to somebody saying, yeah we're working on uh you know drivers that we've been maintaining since the year 2000 then you are low level you are historical you're probably not much past c plus you know it's just like it's kind of like it's kind of it's tidy c with a sprinkling of a few c plus plus features um but it's probably quite imperative and it's quite low level and it bears more it has more in common with c coding style than it does with what somebody would be saying hey guess what you can do this with c++ 23 and so you're it's kind of like am i learning old am i learning anglo-saxon
我是在学习现代，现代英语，你知道，这种变化是巨大的，一种语言的知识并不一定赋予你在另一种语言中的能力。是的，这种语言有文化，有一种文化的想法实际上非常有趣，我最近在工作中做了更多 Python 的事情，特别是试图弄清楚我们如何以 Python 的方式做事，这对我来说太迷人了，在 Python 中，他们有这个术语，他们创造了这个术语来表示，就像我们做事的方式，你知道，就像正确的方式。它真的就像 Python 风格是他们的文化。我前几天和我的女朋友谈论这个，我告诉她，就像，
am i learning modern uh modern english um you know it's the variation to be that huge and knowledge of one doesn't necessarily gift you with ability in the other yeah the this idea of languages have a culture having a culture is actually very interesting i i've been doing more python stuff at work recently and in particular trying to to figure out how do we go about doing things in a pythonic way and it's so fascinating to me that in Python, they have this term, they've coined this term to mean like the way that we do things, you know, like the proper way. And it's really like Pythonic is their culture. And I was talking to my girlfriend the other day about this and I was telling her, like,
这就像，我们在 C++ 中没有这个术语。我们只是说，就像，现代 C++。她建议，而且我认为这是一个很棒的术语，C 加 C。而且我有点喜欢那个，因为 C 加加 C 听起来不太好，但 C 加 C 听起来不错。有趣的是，NVIDIA 很多做 Python 的人，他们不是 20 或 30 年的老手。我不知道 Python 多大了，但他们不是 20 年的 Python 老手。他们是 C++ 人，直到他们开始使用 C++。他们有 C++ 背景，直到，或者他们开始使用 C++。他们有 C++ 背景。然后他们变成了 Python 人。
it's like, we don't have a term for that in C++. We just say, like, modern C++. And she suggested, and I think this is a great term, C plus C. And I kind of like that because C plus plus C doesn't sound so good, but C plus C sounds good. It's interesting where a lot of the people at NVIDIA that do Python stuff, they are not like 20 or 30 year veterans. I don't know how old Python is, but they're not 20 year veterans of Python. They're people who were C++ people until they started out in C++. They have a background in C++ people until, or they started out in C++. They have a background in C++. And then they became Python people.
这并不是对所有人都适用，但我工作中的一些人，我正在与之交谈的一位工程师更像是，我觉得我不知道在 Python 中做事的正确方式是什么。他们中的一些人就像，我不觉得我一定也知道那个，但我们只是在进行过程中弄清楚它，然后就像我们看着我们如何为 GPU 编写 Python 代码，我们看着它，就像这是
It's not true of all of them, but some of the folks that I work with in a certain engineer I was having a conversation with are more like, I feel like I don't know what the proper way to do things in Python is. And some of them are like, I don't feel like I necessarily know that either, but we just sort of figure it out as we go along and then it's like we look at how we write python code for uh gpus and we look at it and like is this
这真的是 Python 的方式，还是这只是在 Python 中编写 C++ 风格代码的一种方式？而这真的是我们想要的吗？是的。我必须为 Connor 做一个时间说明，那就是 Connor，大约五分钟前，我捕捉到了一些 Henri 时钟报时的音频。而且我想我离得很近。我没有捕捉到整个报时序列，但你会想要去编辑它，也许为了介绍，我不知道它是否会出现，我会，我会用它做点什么
is this really the pythonic way or is this just sort of a way of writing C++ style code in Python? And is that what we really want? Yeah. I have to make a timing note for Connor, which is Connor, about five minutes ago, I captured some audio of Henri the clock chiming. And I think I got up real nice and close. I didn't capture the entire chiming sequence, but you'll want to go edit that in maybe for the intro i don't know if it shows up i'll i'll do something with it
回到你那里，Kevlin，是的，但我认为这种想法，特别是在你有这种混合文化的地方，人们来自一个，他们去另一个，我认为很有趣，因为它塑造了你的思维方式。它塑造了你表达事物的方式。而且，你知道，不同的人以不同的方式回应它。而且这是关于你如何想要学习和整合一种语言的知识到另一种语言，或者你如何工作。有时你把事情分门别类，去，哦，我绝对是——这是——你知道，有时人们去，哦，我有一种编程方式，我将在所有语言中使用它。有时这会推动在另一种语言中被认为是正常的极限。而你的同事看着，去，好吧，那很奇怪。那是，你知道，哦，我在这里使用 C++ 惯用语。
back back to you kevlin yeah i but that idea that particularly where you have this kind of like mixed culture, people come from one, they go to another, I think is interesting because it shapes the way you think. It shapes the way you phrase stuff. And, you know, different people respond in different ways to it. And it's about how you want to learn and integrate knowledge from one language into another or how you work. And sometimes you compartmentalize things and go, oh, I'm definitely – this is – you know, sometimes people go, oh, I've got one way of programming and I'm going to use that in all languages. And sometimes that pushes the limits of what is considered normal in the other language. And your colleagues are looking and going, well, that's pretty weird. That's, you know, oh, I'm using a C++ idiom here.
就像，好吧，在我们那里，我们称之为糟糕的 Python。所以你最终得到在一种情况下可能被认为是好的东西，实际上在另一种情况下最终变得奇怪或糟糕。但与此同时，拥有来自另一个地方的东西也可以为你提供一个你根本不会遇到的解决方案。这只是一种思维方式。它就像那种凹槽，而凹槽不是那样对齐的。那不是你的思维工作方式。但如果你在 Python 中工作，你会去，好吧，等等。我会像这样这样做。我会在这里使用推导式。现在，如果我在 C++ 中工作，那意味着什么？好吧，实际上，也许如果我用范围和 lambda 来思考，那让我接近了。但
It's like, well, we call that bad Python where I come from. So you end up with what might be considered good in one case actually ends up being weird or bad in another. But at the same time, having something from another place can also offer you a solution that you simply wouldn't have come across. That's just a way of thinking. It's just like the kind of the grooves and the grooves were not aligned that way. That's not the way your thinking worked. But if you were working in Python, you go, well, hang on. I would do this like this. I would use a comprehension here. Now, what would that mean if I'm working in C++? Well, actually, maybe if I think in terms of ranges and lambdas, that gets me close. But
那是一种非常不同的处理问题的方式。所以你有这些关于表达差异的想法，但然后你有关于什么是这里的正常文化的想法；我昨天在和 Mike Luchides 交谈，很有趣，他是 O'Reilly 的编辑，鉴于我们早些时候在谈论 97 件事，我和 Mike 有，我们每两三周就有一次通话。我们从 2020 年就开始这样做了。我们最初是作为大流行的事情开始的。我们只是保持它继续。我们谈论各种各样的事情。
that's a very different way of approaching the problem. so you've got these these ideas of um differences of expression but then you have the idea of why what's the normal culture here um i was talking funny i was talking yesterday to um uh mike luchides um he's um an editor at uh o'reilly given that we were talking about 97 things earlier and And myself and Mike have, we have a call like every two or three weeks. We've been doing that since 2020. We originally started as a pandemic thing. We just kind of kept it going. And we talk about all kinds of stuff.
我们谈论人工智能、编程语言趋势，你知道，工作空间中真正发生的事情。你知道，元宇宙是人们真正，你知道，这要去向何方，你知道，网络炒作所有这些东西，是的，所以我们谈论了各种事情，他说，好吧，他说，我一直在看一大堆 Python 代码，他说，我没有看到很多推导式的使用，所以推导式基本上是一个非常整洁的，它是一个数学概念。最终，它来自集合意图。所以集合论和谓词演算之类的东西。而且你发现推导式形式几乎，挑选一种函数式编程语言，它会优雅且直接地做到这一点。
We talk about AI, programming language trends, you know, what's really happening in the workspace. You know, is the metaverse a thing that people are genuinely you know where's this going to go uh you know cyber hype all this kind of stuff yeah so we were talking about various things and he was saying well i he said i've been looking at a whole load of python code and he said i'm not seeing a lot of use of comprehensions um and so a comprehension is basically a very tidy it's a a mathematical concept. Ultimately, it comes from set intentions. And so set theory and predicate calculus and stuff like that. And you find comprehension forms pretty much pick a functional programming language, and it'll do that elegantly and directly.
但那不是我们在更命令式的语言中看到的东西。它在 Python 中是后来引入的。当他们在 Python 中引入它时，它已经非常成为核心语言的一部分。它与语法很好地集成。感觉它一直都在那里。它并不总是存在。但其他语言，当我们看 C++ 时，它有点，我们不得不有点推挤，有点接近它，说，好吧，你可以像这样这样做，但那里没有核心概念，所以有一种想法，突然它在核心 Python 风格中变得非常存在，好吧，是的，也许它有，也许没有。它是关于 Python 的公认或交流的智慧。但 Mike 所说的是，是的，当我环顾很多开源 Python 时，我没有看到很多用途。我看到很多命令式风格的编码。每个人都在启动他们的 for 循环和变量，而不是去，你知道，我有一个简单的表达式，它只是像你想要的那样初始化它。
But that's not something that we see in our more imperative languages. It's kind of been brought in later in Python. When they introduced it in Python, it's become very much part of the core language. It integrates with the syntax nicely. It feels like it was always there. It hasn't always been there. But other languages, when we look at c++ it kind of we're having to sort of nudge around and sort of approach it and say well you can do this like this but there's no kind of core concept there and so there is this idea that suddenly it's become very present in the core python style well yeah maybe it has maybe hasn't. It's the received or the communicated wisdom on Python. But what Mike was saying is, yeah, when I look around a lot of open source Python, I don't see a lot of uses. I see a lot of imperative style coding. Everybody's firing up their for loops and their variables rather than going like, you know, I've got a simple expression that just like initializes this the way you want it.
然后我们可以继续我们的真正工作。而相反，你有什么，哦，实际上 for 循环，那是我们的真正工作，而且你有所有这些设置的东西，它分散了代码的主要目的，这实际上回到了 Connor 所说的声明式风格，声明式只是，我只想说这个，我想知道幕后有机器或库来完成这个，我不需要再说一遍，我不需要更明确地说明我如何设置。我只想知道幕后有机器或库来完成这个。我不需要再说一遍。我不需要更明确地说明我如何设置。那不是我在这里的主要目标。有一个清晰的叙述，一个简单的信息，我想传达这一点，并使用可用的抽象机制。但 Mike 所说的是，他说，是的，当我走到野外看 Python 时，我没有看到人们使用这些允许他们这种经济和这种直接表达的构造。
And then we can get on with our real work. Whereas instead, what you've like oh actually four lips that's our real work and you've got all of this stuff that's set up and it distracts from the main purpose of the code which goes back actually to what connor was saying in terms of the declarative style the declarative is just like i just want to say this and i want to know that there's machinery or library behind the scenes that gets this done um i don't need to say it again i don't need to be more explicit about how i'm setting up that's this. And I want to know that there's machinery or library behind the scenes that gets this done. I don't need to say it again. I don't need to be more explicit about how I'm setting up. That's not my main goal here. There's a clear narrative, a simple message, and I want to get that across and use abstraction mechanisms that are available. But what Mike was saying is he says, yeah, when I go out into the wild and look at Python in general, I'm not seeing people using these constructs that allow them this economy and this direct expression.
这是直接表达，但我会争辩说，Python 中的列表推导式，我认为更复杂，不如只写一些 for 循环对新人友好，就像语法，特别是如果你有，你知道，像列表推导式，你在那里也有 if else。就像它变得，它可能变得，我认为可能不直观。是的。使这些东西更复杂是可能的。我永远不会争论这一点。
It's direct expression, but I would argue that list comprehensions in Python, I think, are more complex and not as newcomer friendly as just writing some for loops um like like the the the syntax especially if you've got like you know like a list comprehension where you've got like a um like an if else in there too. Like it gets to be, it can get to be pretty, I think unintuitive maybe. Yeah. It's possible to make these things more complex. I'm never going to debate that.
但我认为这取决于新人来自哪里。是的。我本来想说同样的事情。但他们大多数人来自，大多数人来自命令式编程背景。是的。所以他们在那个方面的本能，这就是重点，他们伸手去拿那个工具。所以它，
But I think it depends on where the new color comes from. Yeah. I was going to say the same thing. But most of them come from, most people come from imperative comes from. Yeah. I was going to say the same thing. But most of them come from, most people come from imperative programming background. Yeah. And so their instinct in that, and that's the point is they reach for that tool. So it's,
它不是对初学者不友好。只是他们思维的凹槽以稍微不同的方式对齐。但当你展示时，哦，是的，实际上这是一个非常，事实上，让我给你一个例子。
it's not that it's not beginner friendly. It's just that the grooves of their thinking are aligned on a slightly different way. But when you kind of show, oh yeah, actually this is a really, in fact, let me give you an example.
这不是 Python，不是 C++，而是 Fortran，我，所以我假设我一定在前世做过一些可怕和邪恶的事情，但我，但在我职业生涯早期，我年纪够大，以至于我最终实际上，你知道，编写 Fortran 并被付钱去做它，而且，我，哪种 Fortran 方言，一定要检查它。而且我……哪种 Fortran 方言？一定要查看这些节目说明，在你的播客应用程序中或在 ADSPthepodcast.com 上，获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及 GitHub 讨论的链接
There's not Python, not C++++ but actually fortran um i uh so for i presume i must have done something in a past life that was terrible and wicked um but i've been but early in my career i am old enough that i've ended up actually you know programming fortran and being paid to do it and uh i which which fortran dialect be sure to check it. And I... Which Fortran dialect? Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion
你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是带有信息点缀的混乱。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。
where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在这里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望您喜欢这期节目，祝您有愉快的一天。低质量，高产量。这就是我们播客的标语。那不是标语。我们的标语是充满信息碎片的混乱。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。